sapete ragazzi che nel mondo ci sono
alcune persone che ancora non
concepiscono il fatto che lo youtuber
sia un lavoro secondo loro io non sarei
in grado di fare un altro lavoro perché
secondo loro lo youtubers non è un
lavoro
sapete cosa dico a queste persone va
bene ma vi siete chiesti veramente che
cosa succederebbe se io facessi davvero
un colloquio di lavoro
buongiorno abbiamo innanzitutto
informare che questo colloquio verrà
ripreso perché dovremmo mostrare le
nostre superiori o qui una scheda che la
descrive ma vorrei che fosse lei a
presentarsi ok ciao
allora io sono fa vj nodi in realtà mi
chiamo lorenzo un libro mi conoscono
anche come fa vj che è un nome strano e
niente e io faccio i video a casa
non faccio video nel senso che registro
mentre faccio cose come giocare ai
videogiochi e basta è questo quello che
faccio quindi non ho ben capito qual è
il suo luogo di lavoro attuale nel casa
mia sta quasi ne del ei suoi strumenti
di lavoro poliziotto
beh uso un computer che va bene compiuto
insomma poi la tastiera è anche una
webcam che serve per riprendere la
faccia perché sa in uno gioca poi si
riprende e al microfono perché poi
prende anche la voce e basta il mouse la
creazione di un palinsesto richiede
grandi abilità strategiche lei pensa di
possederle sicura ma invece sono
ripresentati fatti sono proprio a mio
agio qua è poi comunque sia io che sono
in grado di dirigere persone
perché infatti tante speriamo una volta
ho giocato un gioco dove dovevi
comandare le truppe facevano con quello
kikau andavano molto lì dove chicca la
posizione per cui stiamo facendo questo
colloquio prevede doti di grande
responsabilità vorrei che mi parlasse
del suo percorso accademico quando avevo
tre anni ho iniziato a giocare a metal
gear che sotto il mio primo videogioco
che parla di cospirazioni anche
politiche quindi da meta ghiera applauso
scarse un attimo gesù cristo come ci si
sente bene ha mai fatto uso del social
media
ho smesso no no no no nel senso che
dipende orbita e sono posso darti del
lei non del tutto comunque si io faccio
uso di social media perché ogni giorno
quando esce un video io faccio proprio
vado sulla barra degli indirizzi fi
copia e incolla sulla pagina facebook
poi invio e li fanno vedono con
pubblicato il video
questo è quello che faccio sui social
media mi piacciono le sfide coi due
joystick di vincere un canale richiede
anche doti empatiche nei confronti del
pubblico lei che rapporto ha con il suo
pubblico
beh diciamo che io il mio pubblico ci
parliamo molto chiaramente nel senso che
io faccio video faccio mi immedesimo in
quello che è il mio spettatore quindi lo
spettatore che guarda i miei video più o
meno si rispecchia in meglio
mi rispecchio in loro 15 in virtù di
questa salute la risposta che cosa
vorrebbe vedere solo il suo canale
innanzitutto io metterei le cose che a
me piacciono quindi le cose che so che
piacerebbero ai miei followers dunque
mettere molti anime di serie tv
i film so che è un po complicato questi
diritti guardo sarà però c'è qualche
titolo in particolare si si ad esempio
ce n'è uno che si chiama mi piace tanto
unanime si chiama highschool of the dead
che ci sono tanti zombie e le tipe a
nord se non molto prosperoso ben
esistono macchie sul suo curriculum è il
mio curriculum lo portò sempre tipo
fatto social face l'altro giorno feriti
dalle torte un po fosse sporcato
ma tanto proprio secondo me infatti
devono cambiarlo comunque si paio 2 300
lei ha doti di flessibilità serietà
concretezza impegno apertura mentale
capacità di motivare gli altri di
informatizzare i problemi
guardi cosa so fare inflessibilità
simili pregio grazie non le faremo
sapere
secondo voi è andata male male male
miscredenti
sta arrivando
[Musica]
benvenuti io sono fa vj e sono il
direttore di questo canale ha
esattamente l'ondata di entusiasmo che
stavo cercando sto per rendere questo
canale
l'esperienza televisiva più bella che
voi abbiate mai visto ho scelto un
palinsesto di titoli che mi piace un
sacco ci sono film serie tv cartoni
animati o anche la lista qui
[Musica]
no non è neanche questo questa è la
lista ragazzi impazzirete adesso vi
leggo qualche titolo residenti vol
highschool of the dead south park e sono
solo alcuni dei titoli che vedrete
quindi domande bene alla sentita ragazzi
vado a farmi un giro vede temi non fare
troppo casino per faccia gente che
lavora sì sì
bella zitti ragazzi e benvenuti alla
fine di questo video faccio la intro
alla fine ma [ __ ] di sempre che
questo era uno sketch che avevo da parte
da un pochettino di tempo e volevo
assolutamente metterlo perché vi spiego
in realtà questa cosa è stata fatta per
lanciare il fatto che per questa
settimana qui quindi a partire da questo
lunedì fino ad arrivare a questa
domenica è stato lanciato su sky un
nuovo canale che si chiama sky
generation è stato lanciato da sky
atlantic ed è un canale temporaneo si
chiama pop up channel è chiamato così
vuol dire che esiste per un breve
periodo di tempo io precisamente
esisterà dal 29 ottobre al 20 novembre
sul canale 111 di sky e dove dove sta il
fatto il fatto è che mi hanno messo come
direttore di questo veramente hanno
messo meno non è uno scherzo
anche a me va strano prova viste le mie
doti da direttore che il mio percorso
accademico comunque ragazzi visto che
per questa settimana io sono il
direttore di questo canale ho inserito
film serie tv cartoni animati e roba
[ __ ] che a me piace tipo che mi sono
messo appunto ai di school of the dead
soft parco messo un sacco di roba [ __ ]
che so che vi piaceri di ragazzi
persiste c'erano fatti apposta per
lanciare questa roba del programma però
io volevo mettere links in un blog
quindi non dedicarci un video intero
però riguardando ve li ho voluto farci
proprio un video perché secondo me
meritava troppo come cosa cioè troppo
figlia avere gazzoli spero che vi sia
piaciuto spero che dà anche i
miscredenti che non pensavano io fossi
in grado di fare un colloquio si siano
ricreduti dopo questo cosa insieme
bisogno di un commento è un mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook con inviato
tenere schizzare se non si discute amici
vi chiama non possiamo video e ragazzi
avete qualcosa da chiedermi che
sciaffusa che mi piace questo che
scrisse che sul mood grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]